last night more than 13 million people
watch The Voice coaches react to what
they may have thought was a newcomer
she sent Christina and Blake's spinning
and lit up Twitter but Tamar Davis is no
newbie at 11 years old I joined a group
and it was called girls time girls time
known as Destiny's Child we had summer
parties and played jokes on each other
then my parents decided to take me out
of the group we wanted her to get an
education Destiny's Child has definitely
been through a lot as far as I remember
while Beyonce was telling et about her
group's evolution Tamar was in college
she then sang background for prints and
starred in several of Tyler Perry's
madea's projects have to do is a little
clean I'm allergic
I always put myself in the background
never come into the front and last night
she killed it as Tyler Perry watch
backstage
Tamar's Pig coach Christina who had a
big moment with another contestant Joe
May rejected last season had an easy
decision after Aguilera did this
spontaneous duet I picked her stable